anybody who you expected to be here in
Cambodia who isn't huh you know I
thought there was one guy Shane who is
crazy and was most famous for having a
you know a wooden blackberry a fake
blackberry mm-hmm
I thought Shane would probably make it
because he was so colorful and fun to
watch but what I realized was that might
not be what it takes because if the
people that like Shane mm-hmm are people
like me I don't vote
I'll watch a show and root for somebody
but I'm not gonna pick up my phone and
vote and if they don't win I go on it's
a bummer so it could just be that Shane
had people like me that when I'm not
gonna vote and people like your mom
calling in and voting for Jeremy exactly
because my mom would say Oh Shane was
crazy I don't know yeah anybody that's
been on the show before though like
let's say an Elizabeth Hasselbeck right
that you potentially reached out to yeah
Elizabeth Hasselbeck has said no to us
it to the point of saying don't call me
anymore I'm done so we've given up on
Elizabeth but there was one guy we
really wanted Greg Buist was on the
first season okay along with Kelly and
was famous for really just being so much
outside of the game that he would talk
to his coconut phone him yes okay yes I
know who you're talking about and he was
just a really likeable odd funny sense
of humor and he really wanted to do it
but he had just taken on a job for a
non-profit a CEO and he said I just
can't do it to him and so he said no but
for the most part the response was oh my
god I'm in chorus hang up the phone of
course so obviously these castaways knew
they were coming on the show knew who
else was right on the show how much
pregame game play took place I'm
guessing a ton I would think that
everybody talked to everybody and some
people let us know you know some people
would say I just gonna let you know who
called me and then others people would
say I know they're telling you I called
I didn't call anybody and I look at that
and think everyone's playing everybody
include
me you're playing me right but pregame
alliances they don't mean anything to me
and I've talked to enough former players
who say they really don't work out that
well because you don't know what tribe
you're going to be on you don't know if
there's going to be a switch you don't
know who's going to be voted out and if
you put all your eggs in a pregame
alliance and something changes you have
to play survivor based on the moment and
assess and reassess all the time so I
say talk all you want you don't know
what we have in store for you there's
the season 28 for members for members
from one season brains brawn and beauty
is really interesting because if we do
our job right we'll put two on one tribe
and two on the other so now do you have
an asset and an ally or do you have
somebody who's going to force you one of
you to be voted out it depends how you
look at me some people might say let's
join them there are two votes already
others might say no let's take one of
them out right away
and you're going but I didn't do
anything just because I played on the
season with Kass doesn't mean I like her
yeah so survivor is an equal opportunity
game it's the same reason you can bring
back Boston Rob with a bunch of new
players and people say is that fair yes
you decide who stays do whatever you
want it's your game yeah oh he should
have got rid of him right at the
beginning they're crazy they were
enamored by him and this is why we would
disagree I would look at Boston Rob and
say a really good player is going to
teach me and take me further I just need
to have my knife out before he's
expecting it and get him yeah